Dear friends, thank you so
much for being here today.
And I want to especially
thank Claire Messud, who
has been driven hoarse by her
various speaking engagements.
I want to thank her for agreeing
to speak to us this evening.
The best thing one
can do in introducing
an author to her audience
is to get out of the way
as soon as possible.
I mean to do just
that after paying
a short tribute to Claire,
a dear friend and a valued
colleague.
Claire is senior lecturer
in the English department
and host's the Writers
Speak series at the Mahindra
Humanities Center.
For me, one of the
great experiences
of working with Clare to
establish the Writers Speak
series has been the experience
that if you look around today,
there is absolutely no
question-- you don't even
have to work that hard to
see that the very cannon
and the very archive
of writing in English
has changed dramatically.
While departments
are agonize over how
to diversify their
syllabus, their syllabi
in their curriculum,
here we have
hosted writers who we
have chosen because we've
been interested in
them, and they've
been interested in coming.
They come from all
over the world.
They're writers,
some of whom actually
was first language is
Spanish, who write in French--
the diversity these days
amongst minority writers
and amongst writers,
who although they
belong to a majority
or take a very
oblique view on the
tradition, it's remarkable.
And this has been one of the
great things about this series
that we have had
writers who have just
been chosen by us-- the
quality of their work
and we realize how great
the archive is today.
And if you actually don't
think in those terms,
If you don't give new
voices, older voices,
voices from elsewhere
a chance, then you're--
you are depriving,
suffocating the archive
of contemporary writing.
And I think that's been
a great experience.
Claire is a recipient of
the Guggenheim and Radcliffe
fellowships, and
the Strauss living
award from the American
Academy of Arts and Letters.
The Burning Girl, published
at the end of August,
is her sixth book.
The best writers, and Claire
is simply one of the very best,
create a world that we recognize
as our own as our belonging,
while helping us to explore
ways in which we might realize
our longing to plot
our lives afresh
or to desire the same old
things all over again.
As we struggle to experiment
with the precarious perversity
that exists in what we
thought was predictable,
great writers never
say, "I told you so."
They tell us another story
and then another one that
doesn't beam the truth
straight into our eyes,
but redirects our gaze to take
in a more complex chiaroscuro.
Claire Messud's writings
explore deep veins
of irony and affinity.
But there is no cynicism in her
vision, no immodesty of purpose
or prose.
As a friend and a writer,
our favorite authors
are often both, she remains
happily an intimate stranger.
Claire engages with the
messiness of the moment
as it unsettles social rife and
renders psychic life fragile.
She places us, her characters
and readers, at an angle
to what might be called
the face to face.
Like the elsewhere
acoustic of echoes,
we hear ourselves entering
the world of her fiction
from a distance, emerging into
a slow, yet deliberate process
of self-awareness.
The Burning Girl, a fable
of childhood friendship
lost and found,
coiled and recoiled
has the eerie accuracy of
an everyday school yarn--
slights, fights, envy, ennui--
that turns the ordinary into
augury and the predictable into
premonition.
Julia, the narrator, sums
it up in a wonderful phrase,
which suggests that when you
proceed with instincts rather
than logic, it's difficult to
know whether you are thinking
like a child or a prophet.
The Burning Girl
bears some resemblance
to a coming of age novel, but it
is considerably more than that.
It is, in my view, a
coming of rage novel.
A novel that spares
nothing in trying
to understand how
relentless and redemptive,
how desperate and defiant is
the power of making a story
and telling a story to
oneself or to others
to survive the trauma of
the transitions in our life.
Like the mythic Cassandra,
these burning girls--
Cassie Burns, Julia
Robinson and Claire Messud--
with their ferocious gifts
of prophecy and poetry
torched the quiet town of
Royston, Massachusetts.
Wait for it.
And now, let me
get out of the way.
Thank you, Homi, for that
beautiful introduction.
I feel like I should
just go home now.
That was the was so great.
And thank you all
for being here.
I know it is a
rough time of term,
so it's extraordinary
that you guys are here.
Thank you for coming along.
So you're a captive
audience, huh?
One of the things that--
I've been giving readings
over the course of the fall.
And one of the things
that's become clear
is that people don't
actually much want
to hear readings anymore.
They come, but they want
you to talk and not read.
But I thought, well, today,
I could actually read.
So I thought I would
do that if that's OK.
And I thought I would just read
a couple of pages from the very
beginning that's-- that set
it up and then a scene--
whoops-- a scene
from a bit later on.
The novel is narrated
by Julia and she's
telling it from just the
summer before her senior year
in high school.
She's talking about her
best friendship with Cassie
and it's dissolution
or unraveling.
The book is divided
into three sections.
The first section is
the summer after--
the summer between
sixth and seventh grade.
The second section, which
I think of as time passes,
is seventh and eighth.
And the third section
is in-- takes place
in the spring of ninth grade,
by which time the jig is up.
It's a different story depending
on where you start, who's good,
who's bad, what it all means.
Each of us shapes our
stories so they make
sense of who we think we are.
I can begin when Cassie
and I were best friends,
or I can begin when
we weren't anymore,
or I can begin at the dark
end and tell it all backward.
There's no beginning
before though, Cassie and I
met at nursery school and I
can't remember a time when
I didn't know her, when I didn't
pick her sleek white head out
of a crowd, and know exactly
where she was in a room,
and think of her
some ways as mine.
Cassie was tiny with
bones like a bird.
She was always the
smallest girl in the class
and the span of her ankle
was the span of my wrist.
She had shiny white blond hair,
almost albino she was so fair,
her skin translucent
and a little pink.
But you'd be wrong
to mistake her size
and pallor for frailty.
All you had to do was to
look into her eyes, still
blue eyes that turned
gray in dark weather
like the water in the quarry.
And you could see
that she was tough--
strong I guess is a better word.
Although, of course, in the
end, she wasn't strong enough.
But even when we
were small she had
a quality about her, a "what
the hell" and "I'm not chicken,
are you?" sort of way.
According to my mother
and to Cassie's mother,
Bev, Cassie and I became friends
in the second week of nursery
when we were four years old.
That was always the story,
though I can't tell now
whether I remember it or have
just been told so many times
that I invented the memory.
I was playing with a group
of kids in the sandbox.
And Cassie stood in the middle
of the playground, hands
at her sides like a zombie,
staring at everything,
not apparently nervous,
but totally detached.
I left my friends to
come touch her elbow
and I said, so I was told, "hey,
come build a castle with me."
And she broke into that
rare, broad smile of hers.
A famous smile
made all the better
when she was [INAUDIBLE]
by the Georgia Jaggar
gap between her front teeth.
She came with me back
to the sandbox and that,
my mother always said, was that.
So the first section--
well, I'm really
struggling with that wire.
The first section, which takes
place in this summer just
before middle school--
the girls have been volunteering
at the animal shelter.
And Cassie gets bitten by a
dog and has to have stitches,
and so they can't volunteer
there anymore for a while.
And so they need
something to do.
And Royston, which is a
town that doesn't exist,
but if it did exist
would be not far
from where Georgetown,
Massachusetts, is,
if that gives you some idea.
Th-- there's a quarry outside
the town that they know about,
and they decide to make
their way to the quarry
and beyond the quarry they
know somewhere in the woods
is an abandoned asylum.
So there are--
Homi and I will be chatting.
I don't want to go on about it.
But what-- the intention was a
very simple melody with riffs.
The intention wasn't
a archetypal story
of American adolescent
girlhood in which
the quarry and the
abandoned asylum
have their archetypal quality.
But I-- so I thought I
would read about them--
their first visit to the asylum.
And they've been looking for it.
They've been stumbling through
the woods and they have--
and they come upon it.
The sad building
loomed enormous.
We crested the hillock
toward the light and at first
could see nothing but more
sky down the other side.
100 yards down the slope,
we broke out of the trees
into what had obviously been
a large lawn, a field now.
It's long grasses swaying in
the hot sun, the desperate saw
of crickets all around.
Wildflowers were scattered
through the grasses--
flashes of pink,
purple, and orange
in the bleached ripples--
coneflowers, cosmos,
calendula, coreopsis.
And the air is so long
moist between the trees
smelled dry, a late
summer smell of safety.
The long grassy stretch
broken here and there
by wispy saplings ended in
steps leading to a stone patio.
We'd come up the back.
Instead of the circular drive,
the portico, and the garages,
we were confronted by
banks of darkened windows
like eyes in the three story,
u-shaped, brick facade,
as if the building were
an almost human monster.
On the ground floor, on
the wings at either side,
we could see brown
painted metal doors.
But in the middle
of the U, it's basin
if you will, stretched a
span of French windows giving
onto a terrace and there
just for a moment you could
picture the rich man's residence
the house had originally been.
You could imagine the
French doors ajar, curtains
fluttering in the breeze.
On the terrace a
few tables shaded
by large parasols and a house
party of elegant men and women
drifting, holding China
tea cups or smoking cigars.
Then you noticed the
heavy padlocked chain
that ran through the
doors institutional bars--
rusty but still newer than
the general disintegration
it first suggested.
Some poorly scrub blue graffiti
stretched along one wall.
We could make out, "go
Cavaliers," our high school ice
hockey team and motherfuckers.
"Lunchtime," I said, when
we reached the patio strewn
not only with leaves,
but with shards of glass
and strips of roof tile with
crushed beer cans and cigarette
butts.
I slapped myself down on the
top step, the house behind me
and the hairy green forest we'd
come out of in front of me.
And I opened the backpack on
the [INAUDIBLE] stone edge.
I laid out the tea towel from
my mother's clean kitchen
and on it I placed
the items one by one--
the carrot and cucumber
sticks, the hard boiled eggs
with their little sealed packets
of salt filched from diners,
the sandwiches wrapped in
foil, the camelback of lemonade
and the one of iced
tea their ice cubes
long melted after our trek.
While we ate, Cassie
stalked the terrace,
squinting in at the windows,
grasping her sandwich
with both hands in
her distinctive way,
made slightly
comical by the fact
that one hand was a gauzy paw.
What did we know
about the asylum?
Not much.
It had been built at the
turn of the last century
by a textile merchant named
Ebenezer Otis to house
his collection of Asian art.
His mills were in Lowell.
His city house was on
Commonwealth Avenue in Boston.
But this, outside Royston,
was his country estate.
The fortune was lost
in the crash of '29.
And the house and the
art had to be sold.
Some giant vases, ivory
dragons, and lacquered chests
were acquired by the
Peabody Essex museum
where a couple are
even on display.
The state ended up buying the
property at a discount price.
Where were the Otis
descendants today?
In condos on the
outskirts of Gloucester.
And after leaving it empty
for a few lean years,
they converted it to a women's
mental asylum, the Bonnie
Brook.
I guess there was
that brook at least.
It housed up to
45 women at a time
stricken with a gamut of
complaints-- depression, mania,
schizophrenia, addiction.
According to the
official records,
many got better and went
back to their real lives.
Time passed, views changed,
laws and funding with them.
By the late 1980s, it was
seen as unsalvageable.
And by '93, the Bonnie Brook
was shuttered, forgotten.
Part of the same parcel
of land as the quarry,
it was sold to a
consortium that then
couldn't agree on its fate--
whether to refit
it as apartments
or restore it as
a mansion hotel.
Word was there'd been
a dragging lawsuit.
It had been padlocked and empty
longer than I'd been alive.
I imagined that the
building carried
the sadness of the women
who been trapped there.
The anorexic teenagers, and
the young mothers who heard
voices, and the old women
shattered past repair
by their tragedies.
I didn't see them.
There was no visible mass
of ghosts peering out
of the hollowed windows,
but I couldn't help but feel
they marked the territory.
Cassie didn't feel that way
at all, quite the opposite.
She wouldn't be put off.
I trailed after her as
she walked the perimeter
and climbed a
rickety fire escape,
fruitlessly rattling the windows
in their frames on each floor.
When we reached the front of the
house, its broad circular drive
long overgrown and its crumbling
stables off to one side,
she counted the entrances--
six ground floor windows,
three visible doors
and divided them between us.
As I tugged half-heartedly
at a bolted knob,
I heard the tinkle
of glass breaking.
I looked to see Cassie curiously
bent, her ear against a window
and her paw to the frame.
Her good arm stuck up
inside its shattered pane
like she was birthing a calf.
"Are you fucking insane."
She didn't turn her head.
Her tongue stuck out
between tight lips,
the way it did when she
concentrated in math class.
But she paused
long enough to say,
"It's going to work, Juju,
I'm going to get it."
And after a minute
more of trying,
"I didn't break the window, you
know, it was already broken.
I just knocked the bits
sticking out along the edges."
"Tell that to the jury."
"Christ, what's
wrong with you," she
stuck her tongue out
again, twisted and fiddled,
and paused again.
"Can't you see
this could be ours.
Our own world.
A real world that we found,
and we made and we kept.
Our real secret."
When she put it that way
I suddenly understood.
The mansion looked different,
no longer a house of sorrows
or a hideout for
drunk hockey players
from the high school
or a possible flophouse
for escapees from the
penitentiary up the highway.
I could see it--
the Bonnie Brook
as a magical place
we could invent, the two
of us and have us ours--
the way we thought of
it before I saw it.
A stage for our best
imaginary adventurers.
Like seeing the hot sun
and the crickets as a gift,
like the bright wild
flowers, instead of
as a sinister menace.
Like we had the power,
Cassie and I, the two of us
12 years old, to make anything
into what we wanted it to be.
I said, "Let me try.
My arms longer."
Cassie and I looked at
each other almost smiling,
but not, a kind of
mutual Mona Lisa look.
She extricated her
good arm, careful not
to nick herself on any
protruding fragments,
straightened and stepped
away, crunching broken glass
on the gravel as she went.
I took Cassie's place
and folded myself
like a strange origami,
my cheek pressed
against an unbroken pane
and my neck stretched flat
along the rib of the window,
and my left arm, my writing arm,
I always thought faintly
guiltily my better arm,
up inside the house
squirming and reaching.
The air inside the house was
cooler, fresh on my skin.
I could feel the
lock, but I wasn't
able to reach quite high
enough to flick it from one
side to the other.
Cassie started to laugh.
"What?"
"Did I look like that?"
She made a crazy face.
"It's hard.
You don't need to tell
me," she laughed again,
light in her bird bones
like the wind in the grass.
"It's not going to work."
My sweat left a film on the
window when I pulled away.
"It's got to work," Cassie
said, "we're going in."
I peered in the window.
We stood outside a big common
room with fancy moldings
on the ceiling and
wainscotting waist high.
The plaster was crumbling
and in places mold
bloomed giant flower
paintings along the walls.
A dozen folding
chairs stood stacked
in rows against the far wall
and old paint cans rusted
in piles next to a swing door.
The air in the gloom was
hazed with dust and the floor
once fancy parquet, the kind
you might find in a ballroom,
was strewn with debris,
with plaster crumbs,
and plastic bottles
and what looked
like a layer of dried mud.
From the ceiling hung two
wagon wheel chandeliers,
ugly clunky things
surely acquired cheaply
to replace whatever had
originally been in the house.
A long buffet bar extended
along the far wall.
Next to the chairs,
the dining hall.
Cupping my eyes
against the window,
I could almost see
the institutional room
with its stacks of
damp fake wood trays
and stringy haired
shiftless girls barely older
than me lined up
before steaming vats
of baked beans and
soggy broccoli.
Some hideous perversion
of summer camp
where you didn't get any
care packages and nobody
came to take you home.
I could see too the
parquet sparkling
beneath the crystal
chandeliers that
once had hung from
their sunburst moldings
and the flickering wall
sconces along the walls,
this diffuse and
inconstant light
illuminating again the
faces of girls and boys
not so much older than me,
but in a different life.
One of spangled baubles
and velvet dresses.
The young men in dinner jackets.
A jazz band installed
in the rooms
back right corner where
I could swear a dais
had been placed
precisely for them.
Instead of the plastic paneled
buffet bar with its red heat
lamps, long cloth covered tables
bore silver tureens of punch,
and pyramids of petit fours
and chocolate strawberries.
And behind these stood a quiet
row of young men and women
in dark uniforms,
the staff attending
to every whim of the North
Shore's gilded youth.
Just a big abandoned room,
almost empty, but like Cassie,
I understood now
that we had to go in.
I suggested breaking the window
pane above the broken one, that
would put the window latch
firmly in my fingers.
We knew we were crossing a line.
This went further than trying a
joint with Devon McIntyre down
in the cemetery at Luna's end
of school party back in June
or then Cassie filching a
20 from her mother's wallet
to buy a jumbo bag of
Skittles and big gulps of Coke
at the multiplex when Bev had
expressly forbidden us to.
This was lawbreaking.
The sign on the gate out at the
road did say, "No trespassing.
Trespassers will be prosecuted."
And we were already
trespassing and were
about not just to enter,
but to break and enter.
But it felt necessary, like we
didn't really have a choice.
I made Cassie stand
far back while I
broke the window because
I didn't want the glass
to bounce up and hit her.
And I didn't want the fragments
to get in her bandage.
She stood by with
the otherworldly look
she'd worn when we crossed the
field, a look, if you like,
of destiny.
When we'd climb through the
open window, Cassie whooped.
A testing sort of whoop,
louder at the end,
that echoed in the hollow room.
Then she spun in circles,
arms outstretched,
leaving swirling marks
along the dusty floor,
whooping the whole time.
I fussed about a glass cut
along my elbow, not deep,
but I squeezed out a
little rivulet of blood
that I wiped with my
finger and sucked.
My mother always told me that
if you don't have disinfectant
you want to make sure
the cut bleeds cleanly
to wash the germs out.
So that's what I did first.
We push the swinging door to
check out the kitchen's two
big rectangular
rooms, laid end to end
with black and white
checkerboard flooring
like at my house,
but miles of it
like something out of
Alice in Wonderland
and rows of stainless
steel counters
dulled by years of filth.
Cassie tried the taps at
one of the industrial sinks,
but nothing came
out, which was just
as well as it would have flushed
the complex spider's web spun
across the sink itself.
We opened some cabinet doors,
not metal, but painted wood
or once painted wood.
And when we left them open
the doors dangled drunkenly
on their hinges,
but found nothing
except a clutch of
stiffened paint brushes
and an ancient, empty
gallon plastic Coke bottle.
"People have been
here," Cassie pointed
to some sticky rings in the
dust on one of the countertops,
"before us."
"Not for a long time."
"Do you think the Coke's from
when they moved everything out
20 years ago or from last year
when, say, DeLouis Runyon was
hiding out here."
DeLouis Runyon was a high
school junior from Worcester,
famous because he beat
up his math teacher,
also his hockey coach, and ran
away before the cops got him.
He was missing for 72 hours
and then turned himself in.
Nobody knew where he'd been
exactly or they weren't saying.
But he hadn't been
at the Bonnie Brook,
we were too far from Worcester.
Most likely he'd been in
his girlfriend's garage.
"Last year?
I doubt it, but maybe
not so long as 20 years.
Remember the chains on
the doors at the back?
They're newer than that.
So maybe they had a problem
with people, you know,
coming in a while back,
like five years or 10
and put the locks on."
We both considered
the crazy number
of days in which
this building had
stood empty, how
any one of them--
far more days than either
of us had been alive,
though not quite as many as
all of our days put together.
In this house
anything could have
happened and most
strangely of all,
how on most of those days,
even almost all of those days,
nothing had.
Sure, kids like us
had broken in before
and hung out drinking
on the patio.
And maybe a few times some nut
had spent a night here, maybe
even half a dozen nights.
Imagine someone had even
lived in the Bonnie Brook
for a month, that would still
leave 17 years and 11 months,
well over 6,000 days and
nights of total silence.
A once human habitation
uninhabited, given over
instead to spiders, and
chipmunks, and robins,
and potentially
the occasional fox.
It overwhelmed in
the way the night
sky overwhelms when
you lie on your back
in the grass and stare at it,
at all the tiny points of light.
And imagine the
unimaginable distances
between those stars and
earth and how long even
the light has taken
to get to your eye,
so long that maybe the star
that emitted that light
is already, in
actuality, long gone.
"I vote we see upstairs
first," Cassie said.
In the front hallway, we
peered up the staircase
at the big stained glass
window with its lilies
in a vase and crimson tracery--
only a few panes knocked
in, their bright fragments
scattered on the wood floor.
Someone had pulled up boards,
leaving rutted gaps underfoot.
But the newel post at
the bottom of the stairs
had proven too sturdy
for the thieves.
It's carved finial was the
size of my head, a great, once
polished ball of patterned
flowers and vines.
A vinery traced all up the
banister and the length
of the balustrades as well.
"Can't you see the grand
ladies coming down,"
Cassie breathed at my ear,
"in their evening dresses."
"Sure, I can," I said,
and it was true, I could,
"and right behind
them, do you see
the crazy girls in blue smocks
with their hair sticking up
anyhow and wild eyes.
Do you see them, too?"
I gave a great
cackling laugh that
resounded up the stairwell--
an evil mad woman's laugh.
"That's the noise
they're making.
Can you hear it?
It's wicked loud."
"Don't," Cassie pressed my arm.
We both looked up the
stairs at the dust motes
drifting in a shaft of
sun across the landing.
We could feel them with us.
I knew she did,
just as much as I.
And they too were our sisters.
"Don't."
To be in that ruin
with Cassie, it
was such a particular feeling
that I've had nowhere else.
If ever I have it again,
I will recognize it
like a long lost scent, and
that afternoon and the ones that
followed will return to me in
all their visceral intensity.
The Bonnie Brook was at once the
most unlikely, vivid experience
of our lives up till
then and like a dream--
a dream miraculously
that Cassie and I
dreamed in tandem, touching,
hearing and feeling together.
The asylum was darkened
by the traces of its past,
made titillating even
scary by its silences,
but made safer too
by our sharing it.
Being in the Bonnie
Brook was like being
inside both Cassie's head and
my own, as if we had one mind
and could roam its
limits together,
inventing stories
and making ourselves
as we wanted them to be.
I'll stop there.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Claire, thank you very much.
It's wonderful to be read to.
I think people don't quite
realize how comforting it is.
People have mixed
feelings about it.
Some people really dislike it.
Those are the
competitive people who
want to hear their own
voices all the time.
Maybe, maybe.
But let me ask you something.
When you were writing
this book you said to me,
this is a small book.
I'm writing a small book.
I've written a small book.
And I want to ask
you about that.
I want to ask you about scale.
In fact, I thought we'd
talk about four things
and then open up
to the audience.
One is scale.
The other is voice,
love, and narrative--
four aspects.
Four small things.
[LAUGHTER]
Well, I mean small in
the sense in which you
claim this is a small book.
I mean, in the same sense.
So I mean, you know, I
know that Conrad thought
that Heart of Darkness was a
small book that he was writing
in between Lord Jim.
He couldn't quite do
it, and he thought
he should write a small book.
And I think Thomas Mann
thought Death in Venice
was also relatively
a small book.
What makes a small book small?
What is it?
I'm interested in
the scale question.
It's short.
[LAUGHS] I mean, you
know, it's interesting.
Do better than that.
I'll try.
I mean, it's interesting.
Because a number of people
that you said to me, oh, well,
of course, the scale
of, the ambition in this
is so much smaller, less than
in some of your other books.
And I feel like I have been
a little baffled by that.
Because actually, it seems to
me that the challenge for me
was greater.
Or certainly, I mean, it always
seems like a great challenge
whatever you try, right?
If it doesn't seem
impossible, why bother?
But the challenge was
simplicity, right?
So the challenge was to
try to write a story that
would have about it, as you said
in your lovely introduction,
that would have
about it the quality
of a simple bildungsroman,
That would have about it
a sort of familiarity.
But it's like a souffle, right?
Like, I feel like the
aim was, like, a souffle.
The aim was to write something
that people could sit
down and read and just enjoy.
And then I had an idea.
You know, you never know.
Does it work?
Who knows, who knows?
But somebody said to me, oh, I
read your book a second time,
and it was completely different.
It felt like a piece of
quartz, that I turned it--
I turned it, and it
was a different book.
And I felt that was a
great compliment to me.
I mean, I took it as
a great compliment,
because that was what I wanted.
I wanted it to be something that
would seem simple and possibly
even familiar, but
that would have
certain strangenesses
about it that that
would make a reader think, huh.
Well, that clearly
was on purpose.
So what?
Let me look again.
And then upon looking again,
there would be this other,
if you will, this
other story revealed
or these other
questions explored.
Yeah, the souffle
thing only works
because you've got to eat
the souffle straight away.
If it collapses, it actually
doesn't taste that different.
But it loses its
aesthetic standing--
Right.
--so to speak.
But let me say this.
That there's, of
course, another way
of thinking about this, which is
Walter Bingham [INAUDIBLE] way.
That you take the
small thing, which
is polished and
polished and polished,
and it just throws out
all kinds of light.
Now the notion of small and
big is interesting, of course,
in literature.
Because in a funny way, this
is not a bildungsroman, I feel.
It's not, because as I said,
whereas in a bildungsroman
there is a kind of,
at the end of the day,
a sort of moral realism
that takes over.
Here, the rage never stops.
In the end, the dream
at the end, you know,
that great dream at the
end is full of complexity.
It's full of passion and
incest and love bites
all over and unresolved.
I mean, I don't mean
actual love bites.
I mean wounds, you
know, that you see.
But it seemed to
me that a painter--
it's interesting that
Peter is here today--
a painter would never say a
miniature work is a small work.
Because in a way, scale
is about complexity.
And that's why I
felt that I was just
very interested in where
and how you decided to work,
to play out this narrative,
which is about youth
and sexuality and puberty
and growth and death
and the mistakes
of one's parents,
all in this very
compressed form.
Why Royston?
What were you trying to
do with these locations?
You know, my question
is not about context.
It's not about why is
this a small town novel,
is it a big town?
Is it a city novel?
It's more about how you assemble
the different bits of it,
the mythos, the
mythical parts of it,
the fable with the
realist detail,
with the girlish silliness,
with the girlish maturity,
with the fear.
Right.
I mean, it's a good question.
I think one of the things--
there are a couple of
my students here today,
and this is not what one should
say in front of one's students.
But it's all a mystery.
It's all a mystery.
I can't really tell you.
I mean--
Royston is a mystery?
Well, I think what leads
one to make certain--
I mean, I'm actually a
great believer in intuition,
in the id at work.
And I can give you all sorts
of reasons why Royston.
You know, Royston, which
had another name until I
realized that all of the--
it had a Germanish name.
But then I realized,
actually, in that corner
of Massachusetts, all
the names are British.
[MAKES BUZZER SOUND]
If it were upstate New York,
that would be different.
Maine-- that would be different.
You know, there are all
sorts of practical reasons.
I wanted these girls--
and it's interesting.
People talk.
People keep referring to
sort of Julia and Cassie.
Cassie's mother
is a hospice nurse
and Julia's father is a
dentist and her mother
is a freelance journalist.
And people say, well, of
course, upper middle class
Julia and struggling Cassie.
I'm, like, Cassie, in
the scheme of the world,
is not struggling.
Cassie's a middle
class girl, too.
She's perfectly well off.
Her mother's a professional.
I feel as though the ways
people want to talk about--
and that was important
to me-- that it
wasn't a story about girls
who come from radically
different class backgrounds.
One happens to be more stable
and slightly more prosperous.
But they're actually both--
but I wanted them to
be from households
where the understanding and
the prospects looking forward
were quite different.
Which is to say the
difference between a house
where it's assumed you'll
go to college and a house
where that's not an
assumption that all.
And I actually-- maybe
that can happen still
in Cambridge, just about.
But I feel that by the time
you got to high school,
the distances would be greater.
The small town, you
know, this may not
be what you were asking at all.
But there were all sorts
of practical reasons.
I can give you all sorts
of practical reasons
why I needed it to be
a town of this scale.
And I wanted it to be
outside-- in Massachusetts,
but I did not want it to be
Western Massachusetts, which
is a different thing.
I wanted it to be closer to
Boston, all of this stuff.
And because the
quarry, the quarry
was in there from
the beginning, that
was another eastern
Massachusetts thing.
So you know, there were
just all sorts of--
every decision you make sort
of limits the further choices.
And eventually,
you come down to--
I was watching for
the first time--
I'm ashamed I hadn't seen
it before, but Skip's DNA,
you know?
And I feel like
at some point you
do those DNA tests--
it's like, well, you
have only four possible
great grandparents.
That's it, like, right?
I mean, at some point,
it's a similar thing.
You put all this stuff
together, and it is where it is.
But of course, one of
the interesting things
here is that the issue, the
social issues you talk about,
the aspirational issue,
are so finely made, finally
problematized by the fact
that, at this age group,
if you're in school together,
Cassie and JuJu think
the same thoughts.
I was just going
back to your reading.
It doesn't matter that one
is in a single parent home.
The other is somewhat
different [INAUDIBLE]..
And I think that's
the beauty of it.
That there is a
certain point at which
you realize that your
futures and your destinies
are going to be different
unless you really fight them.
But I want to take
up this phrase
you used, the id at work.
And of course, the id
at work in this novel
really is a first
person narrative.
If you think about
it, the id at work,
as it gets a form in this novel,
is the first person narrative.
And this is where I want to
bring in the question of voice,
partly because many of
the reviewers, I think,
have got it the wrong
way around and keep
asking the traditional question
about first person narratives.
Which is, is this
a reliable author
or is this an unreliable author?
This is a, you know,
post-Wayne Booth
in The Rhetoric of Fiction.
Or is there authenticity in
this first person narrative?
Does the narrative hold
together as it goes on?
And of course, there, this
is a work about transition.
So it cannot hold together.
But it seems to
me that this idea
of thinking about
first person narratives
as belonging to persons is
almost less interesting,
as you show in this
book, than the way
in which the first
person emerges
in different mis en scene.
So in the quarry scenes,
the first person narrator
is a different kind of narrator.
In the other scenes
in school, it's
a different kind of
first person narrator.
And there, I thought, was
something very interesting
in this novel, and
didn't allow you
to use the moral calculuses,
is this a [INAUDIBLE]
is it a nonrealistic?
Is it reliable or not--
but, or otherwise.
But you also brought
to mind something else.
Which is that first
person narratives
are vampiric narratives.
They feed-- the narrator
feeds off the life and blood
of somebody else to the
extent to which you ask,
because you do
with, say, Conrad--
why the hell is Marlow
so obsessed with Kurtz?
[LAUGHTER]
But why?
What is there about--
Why is Marlo so obsessed
with Kurtz, or indeed, here--
Julia?
It's almost as if she
doesn't have a life--
[LAUGHS]
--outside of this
obsession with--
She has some.
She makes some other friends.
But she makes-- it is all
so self-conscious, you know?
If I tap this boy's
hand, is he wincing?
Is he not wincing?
Is he coughing?
Is he sneezing?
All very interesting,
but the real issue here
is that without Cassandra--
Right, there is no story.
Yeah.
Right.
But I mean--
There's no person.
But, I mean, there
are various things.
And I think those two
things are not unrelated.
And there is the
fact that we could
say the trajectory throughout--
I mean, for me, this is a book
about this transition from--
I mean, it's about many things.
It's about what happens in
this transition from childhood
to adulthood, from a sort of
state of accepting the world
and however strange it may
be without really questioning
your place in it, to a period--
which is what adolescence is--
when you look up,
and you look around,
and you say, well,
where do I fit in?
And how do I relate to
these people next to me?
If going to her house,
if her house is normal,
my house is not normal.
So which is it,
hers or mine, right?
There's this sort
of taxonomy that
goes on of trying
to sort of order
the world in some way
that seems logical.
And to sort of claim a voice--
and part of claiming a voice,
it comes from absorbing
all the narratives
that we have internalized and
heard and watched and been
told from earliest childhood.
And for me, you know, there
are many, many stories
that are in this simple story.
From Hansel and Gretel to, as
you know, I've said to you--
many years ago, I said,
I think to you, Peter--
I said, when asked, what
would be a sort of influence
or antecedent-- and
I said, Le Grand
Meaulnes the
Alain-Fournier novel.
And--
[INAUDIBLE]
And by and large,
you know, that's
just not a common reference now.
So when I said that to my
editor, she was, like, huh?
But Ursula Le Guin, reviewing
the book in The Guardian
in the UK, said, and
this book reminds
me of Le Grand Meaulnes.
And I felt-- it was great.
It was a little like
the [? quartz ?] moment.
I was, like, well,
OK, maybe it's
only obvious to five
people in the world.
But that's OK.
It's there.
And anyway, but I digress.
But the taking of a
voice is something
that is a mishmash, a sort
of pastiche of all the voices
that we've heard.
And we come into
our adult voices,
such as they are, by a sort of
maceration and bastardization
of all sorts of
different voices.
You Again, a digression,
but you know, expressions
like in any way, shape, or
form that people sometimes
throw in, because it
sounds professional, right?
Because it sounds like--
in any way, shape or form
is actually, strictly
speaking, a phrase that has
no purpose anywhere, right?
It doesn't do anything, right?
It's a kind of taxonomy.
But it sort of sounds good.
And when you're trying
to sound grown up
or you're trying to sound
impressive, you might say,
I don't agree with you in any
way, shape or form, right?
And it it sounds somehow better
than I don't agree with you.
It sounds like
more authoritative.
Or like when you're just about
to spit in somebody's face
you say, with respect.
[LAUGHTER]
No, or as we say at
our house, no offense,
the phrase that presages
certain offense, right?
Like, you don't say
that unless [INAUDIBLE]..
But let me tell you
that, as an undergraduate
at my undergraduate
college in Bombay,
Le Grand Meaulnes
was a set text.
We studied it there.
So amongst the five people
you know, I'm the sixth.
But did you actually mean
to put in the importance
of being patience as playing
off The Importance of Being
Earnest?
No, that may have come--
The importance of being patient,
and I thought, how funny.
This is ripping off The
Importance of Being Earnest.
That one that one will have
come, that one will have come.
But you see, it's all
in there, you know?
I had this experience when
I was reading to my kids,
of discovering-- there was a
book that my sister and I had
loved as children.
And it's called The
Wind On The Moon,
and it's by somebody
named Eric Linklater.
And the New York Review
of Books reissued it.
And when I read it to my kids,
now already some years ago,
I discovered that
all these jokes
that I thought of as
family jokes, that I
thought we made up, no.
They're jokes from
that book, right?
I mean, I felt we were just--
I want to go back to
something you said.
Yes, of course, we
absorb all these voices.
That's why I said, you
know, it's a kind of--
growing up is a kind of
vampiric exercise, you know?
We're all frankensteins
and of a certain kind.
But what I wanted to say--
but here, interestingly,
you pick all those things
up, and then you shape them.
But the point about this
is her making the story.
Yes.
Now you talked about the
taxonomic moment of this time,
in transitions, you know.
What is me is in me and not me.
But the interesting
thing here is not so much
the taxonomic as I read it,
I may be wrong, with respect.
You can read it anyway you want.
But the tropic, the
translational entropic-- so
that she's continually
taking something, taking
the binary taxonomy,
if you like,
and then translating it and
making it into a metaphor
and into a trope, putting
it in different places.
And this, again,
brought back to me
how inadequate the
critical approach
to voice as authentic
or unauthentic,
or voices simply belonging
to one person is.
Because here, the
voice is neither--
in a way, it's JuJu or Julia.
But the real issue is the
tension between her and Cassie.
The voice keeps
going in between.
It's a very citational voice.
So we've done our voice bit.
OK.
Now I want to talk about love,
quickly, and then narrative,
and then open up.
So I thought that there was
a kind of real complex depth
when, you know, the
relationship breaks up, really.
There are attempts where
it sparks up again.
There are expectations
that this will last,
expectations on
Julia's mother's side.
And then it doesn't
last, et cetera.
And then Julia
says, "If my mother
thought it would be the
first visit of many,
she was mistaken.
Cassie was friendly
enough at school,
as if I didn't have
ice shards in my heart,
as if I couldn't possibly.
But she must have
sensed something.
Either that, or she
chose to keep a distance.
I would not, could not make
a significant overture.
My pride depended on this.
She would have needed to
make the effort enough
to be openly vulnerable.
She would have had
to risk my revenge.
I like to think I wouldn't
have rebuffed her,
but it's possible
that I would have."
And at this point,
you also begin--
this notion of risking my
revenge, at a personal level,
is also about risking something
in the making of the narrative.
Because I think
one of the things
you say that you've got to
risk in the narrative is never
to show the whole thing.
You only see the phases
of the moon, which
then allow you to
trace in your mind
the element that you don't see.
It's the old Husserlian
problem of the horizon
being outside of what you see.
Then that made me feel a
wonderful way of bringing
together transitional moments
in one's life and childhood
or otherwise, where you
only see your shadow,
and you can't see the other
side of it, on the one hand.
But also the way in which in
love, and in war, in fighting,
in amity and in animosity,
there is always the risk you
have to take.
I take the risk
of interpretation,
but I also take the
risk of identification.
And I thought those came
through rather beautifully
around the question of love.
Well, thank you.
I mean, I do in a
sort of simple--
as I was saying earlier, I read
a certain amount from the book,
except that people don't
really want me to read.
So I've talked a certain
amount about the book.
And one of the things that I
try to explain is that I had,
at this point, and I know
that a number of my peers
have also in different
ways, experienced
a certain frustration with
realism as it was handed to me,
or as I experienced it, as I've
experienced it as a reader.
And people have sort of dealt
with that in different ways.
Rachel Cusk has sort of followed
a sort of Sebaldian track
of making herself all but--
her narrators all but invisible.
And they tell the
stories of others.
There's a British novelist
named Andrew Miller who
wrote a novel-- in an
interview recently--
that had fantastical elements.
And I read an interview in
which he talked about the fact
that this arose for him out
of frustration with realism.
But I am sort of wedded to
realism in certain ways,
because I'm actually--
that's just who I am.
But it was actually--
I remember speaking
to somebody here
on campus after the
David Grossman event
a couple of years ago.
And he said-- this
professor said,
who came from the social
sciences-- he said,
I love reading fiction.
Because in real
life, nobody tells me
what characters are like.
But in fiction, I get told.
And you know, back to
the [INAUDIBLE] event,
where I cited there's a
moment in The English Patient
where he says a novel is a
mirror walking down a road.
If my job as a writer is a
mirror walking down the road,
I have yet to experience
the moment where somebody
comes up and whispers
in my ear and says,
he is a shy, but kindly, man.
Though he may seem gruff,
his intentions are only good.
Like, I don't have that.
So the book is written--
people have asked is Julia
an unreliable narrator--
I feel, no more than any of us.
We spend our time creating--
we only ever have
partial information.
We only ever see
part of the moon.
And we construct from
what we see and combined
with our experience
of life, we construct
an understanding of other
people, an understanding what's
going on in a room,
an understanding
of the subtext in a
conversation, everything,
everything.
So I, as a writer in this
book, am asking readers to,
as it were, to have that, if
you will, Husserlian experience.
And then to make
decisions-- you know,
what do I think is happening?
What do I think these
relations really are?
What do I think?
And yes, it is in some way--
I've digressed from your
thing about the risk,
both in war and in love.
I was thinking about
North Korea for a second.
Anyway--
You digress.
I digress, yes.
But certainly, that's
true-- that there's always
the possibility that our
constructions are false.
But you know you said--
Or inaccurate.
--that in some way,
you're wedded to realism.
And I thought, you're
wedded to realism
because you are
married to James Wood.
[LAUGHS]
But let me--
I mean, and I think there's
a serious point there.
But let me get back to
something else here.
Which is that I thought in
this book, more than any other,
your particular kind
of realism, which
is a very figurative kind of
realism and you work that.
I mean, it's neither the mirror
nor is it the Balzacian window.
It's a different kind of thing.
But by the end of the
book, as I understood it,
it's not simply that you say
we only have partial knowledge
or we only see the moon,
only see a part of the moon.
It's more or less saying it's
the uncertainty that we occupy.
That's the important thing.
That's why we can't
be truth tellers.
And you actually put that there.
There is a phrase you used.
I can't find it now.
We say, it's the uncertainty.
And that's neither
about realism nor is it
about a kind of
modernism [INAUDIBLE]..
That, to occupy that anxiety,
which your narrator Julia says,
right from the beginning, she
said, I somehow have this--
I'm in this place of anxiety.
And I think that's what
really, in a profound way,
questions the
epistemology of realism.
It's neither that it's
fantasy or it's real,
but that you are hovering.
And that hovering is important.
Yes.
And it seems to me--
and I come now to
my final point--
and I'm very keen to open up--
which is in a way about
the ethics of narrative.
May I just interject one thing?
Yes, of course.
I feel very profoundly that if
we were all as a society more
accepting of uncertainty, we
would be in a better place.
I couldn't agree more with you.
And I think that--
even in the classroom, I
often say to my seminar
the pedagogy, the real pedagogy
of anxiety, is so important.
If there isn't anxiety,
you will not learn.
This does not mean that it's
anxiety which is all-consuming.
But it's an anxiety
which opens you up,
rather than closes you down.
And I think that's
the trick of writing--
whether it's writing
theory or writing fiction--
is to hold that anxiety
in a productive way.
And it seems to me
then that I want
to end with a passage right
towards the end, where
you talk about seeing.
And in a sense, the
subtext, as we've
been talking about first
person narrators, in my mind,
has also been Conrad
to a great extent.
Because historicizing
Conrad never
lets you see the deep
anxiety in Conrad.
Or politicizing Conrad has
to be done through that.
And of course,
Conrad famously said
that it was his desire
to make people see.
And you say, "My curse
is to see things,
to know stories,
how they unfold,
and people, what they're like.
I don't seek to
know these things.
I just do it.
It tires me to be honest.
Cassie got the
prophetic name, but I
got the curse, the Cassandra.
Or the gift, depending
on how you look at it.
What I'd like is for someone
to take the burden from me,
or at least to share it.
If I didn't see, I
wouldn't try to know.
And of course, you
can't ever really know
what happens to
another person or what
they think happens
to them, which
amounts to the same thing.
I can't know what the poisoned
cloak felt like burning
into Cassie's skin.
I cannot even
really imagine it."
So here we come back to the half
moon that makes you narrate.
Because if you saw
it, there would
be nothing to narrate for.
And on the other hand, we
come back to the anxiety
and the anxiety of
the undecidable,
which you have brought
through I think so well here.
But then what is seeing?
What is seeing?
What is seeing in
the way in which you
talk-- what are you seeing?
Is it-- there's
much in this book
about myth and the prophetic.
But what is it to
see as a burden?
Or what is the burden of seeing?
I feel that maybe in a way
the answer I might give
will disappoint.
Because I'll bring it back down
to the level of the everyday.
And it seems to me that the--
people are on a
spectrum from those
who are most chameleon-like
who see to those who are least
mutable and see less.
And that-- you
were saying earlier
about the vampiric nature of
the first person narrative.
The characters at
the least mutable end
are not interesting narrators.
They are interesting for people
to observe and write about.
But you can't imagine Brideshead
narrated by Sebastian Flyte.
I mean it just wouldn't happen.
It's a recurring sort of duality
or whatever throughout I think
certainly 20th century fiction.
And I mean it in life.
Like I can see from earliest
days with my kids' friends
and my kids.
My kids have the gift and
the curse to walk into a room
and read it, and understand
the power dynamics,
and understand how everybody
relates to each other.
And what they then do
or don't do with it
is a whole other story.
But I could see that they had
friends who walked into rooms
and were entirely themselves,
and unchangingly themselves,
and couldn't do anything about--
like maybe it would help
to change your outfit,
or make your voice
a little quieter.
And those kids just couldn't
do it because that's--
because who they were didn't
involve that, if you will,
sort of subjugation of self.
And so I think I
meant for Julia--
it's actually just
articulating something
that I have observed as a
way of being in the world.
That she's someone who--
I mean it's like the difference
between Obama and Trump.
Obama can walk into a
room and find something
in common with anybody from
anywhere and can make--
and that involves showing some
different facet of himself
or changing some aspect
of himself, which doesn't
mean he's a different person.
It's just that there's
some way of reading
other people in the way
he engages with the world.
Trump, not at all.
But when you said that,
that autobiographical note,
it made me think--
if I can be indulgent and
digress for a minute--
that for some of
us who came even
from very privileged backgrounds
in post-colonial societies,
we had to learn this.
And we learned it.
So it was not just a facet
of our de-sovereignizing
ourselves.
But it was we had to learn this.
It didn't matter
you went to Oxford.
And your scout in
the college thought
he should tell you what to do.
And he would-- or you went-- or
you had a tutor who would say,
I don't think--
I remember this happened to me.
I said, you know, I wonder
whether I should now work
on W.H. Auden, who is one of
the great passions of my life,
or on--
and I was at Christ Church.
And I chose to go to Christ
Church because of Auden.
It was the stupidest thing
to do, sitting in Bombay.
It just shows you my kind
of imperial cast of mind.
But I couldn't help it.
I did it.
And I got in.
And so I said,
you know, should I
work on Auden and [INAUDIBLE]?
I really wanted
to work on poetry.
Or should I work on Naipaul.
And he said, no, no, I think
you should work on Naipaul.
And I had to immediately
make a virtue of it.
I felt in some way displaced.
And yet the
conditions were such--
and I'm now deeply grateful
that I immersed myself
initially in the Caribbean.
But we had to do
this the whole time.
We had to adjust.
And it was not from
a position of power--
even if we came from wealthy
parents with good education.
Right.
But the position of sort
of listening and adapting
in that way is never
the position of power
because it's never in
the center of the room.
Well, it does--
You're all around the
edges of the room.
I mean that's what it is
to be the narrator is not
to be the star of the show.
Yeah.
To be the narrator is not
to be the star of the show.
But there are ways
in which you can
be open to melding because you
have a certain savoir faire.
And there are many
people who come
from disadvantaged backgrounds--
even black, white, I
don't care, lilac--
who are intimidated,
who can't do it.
So I just wanted to put--
the art of the
chameleon can also
be the art of a certain kind
of power and disempowerment
at the same time.
Of course.
And I think it is
narratively too.
It is-- I mean you
could say-- back
to this sort of
vampiric first person,
it's the ultimate revenge of the
wallflower to tell the story.
Because at the end of the day,
Cassie doesn't tell her story.
No.
But at the end of the day,
Julia writes the book.
Right.
Good.
So she-- so I think this
vampiric issue interests
me greatly.
And I wanted to float it today
that the first person narrative
is really a vampiric position.
But I said we would talk
about scale, voice, love,
and narrative.
We've done that.
So now let's open up.
Thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]
Questions, please.
Could I have my--
thank you so much.
Jill.
I'm OK.
Thank you.
My question has
to do with the way
that the novel
captures the peculiar,
but to me very
familiar, intensity
of adolescent, preadolescent,
into early childhood
obsessive almost friendship
between two girls.
And listening to you reading,
in my interior thoughts
I was trying to
think of, is there
a novel that captures
that kind of relationship
between boys of that age?
And I thought about A
Separate Peace, which
isn't exactly right, or
Brideshead Revisited, which
both have such overtly
sexualized aspects
to the friendship.
And I guess I'm just interested
in whether, A, either of you
could think of one,
but whether boys
have those kinds of
early friendships
that are basically
pre-sexual but have
the intensity of
this sort of burning,
fervent love and acute
feelings of rejection,
et cetera, et cetera.
Do you?
And Claire, I know
you've raised a boy, so--
Who's-- he won't hear
me say this, right?
But he definitely had a--
Who?
My son had a friend--
Like that?
Like that until about 11.
And I feel that it sort of--
they were at different
schools at that point.
But part of the difference I
think is that girls are verbal.
There's a lot of talk.
And he was so excited
to see that best friend.
But they would go to a
basketball court or a sports
field and, as far
as I could tell,
be a few hundred yards apart
for the entire afternoon.
But he was-- so there
was the intensity.
And then I think--
but it wasn't torture.
There was much less torture.
I [INAUDIBLE]
Out shooting horses?
Uh-huh.
Out Stealing Horses.
[INAUDIBLE]
Right.
That tells that story.
Well, I felt [INAUDIBLE]
the other way.
I thought I could completely
identify with Cassie and Julia.
And I had two such
relationships--
very, very close and
very physically close
without being erotic.
And I don't think either of us
has really got over the break.
And we used to in
Bombay spend our days--
I mean we were on a
prize committee recently.
And he said, do you remember we
used to meet three times a day?
We'd go to college.
I'd come to your
house for lunch.
You'd come to my
place for dinner.
And then we'd go out for a
walk after dinner every day.
I don't think we
ever got over it.
And today, this person
lives in New York.
And I live in Boston.
And he was the
closest thing in my--
until I was 18.
Apart from my
relationships with women,
I mean this was
the closest thing.
And I think the break was
such and I felt it so strongly
that today, we can't
even talk about it.
And because we can't
talk about, it cannot--
it hasn't brought us together.
And I actually felt
that, as you said,
the verbal nature of
these relationships,
the verbal nature of them,
the sharing of fantasy,
the sharing of making
up stories, that I think
gets sublimated by sports and
that whole public spectacle.
And he and I
couldn't do anything.
We could play a little cricket,
but neither of us was any good.
And so we spent
a lot of our time
reading and talking and making
up stories, that kind of thing.
But I funnily enough
felt very close
to the experience in this book.
And I thought, what a strange
thing gendered relationships
are in different contexts.
And I am speaking from
the context of Bombay.
Something I think
also reminds me--
it's very different
because it's not
a relationship between boys.
But I think the
relationship between Kim
and the lama is actually-- there
are many similarities there
because in many ways, Kim is the
adult. The lama is the child.
They have a very close
both physical and social
relationship.
There's a complete breakdown
of childhood in Kipling.
I think there's a
lot more to that book
about the nature of childhood.
And it is interesting
that it's a kind
of Western boy of mixed
and unknown parentage,
now chameleon-like in India.
It's something about that
relationship that strikes me
as being one
between boys and not
really a mentorial
relationship, although that's
the way it's formally set up.
So I grew up in the Middle East.
So I've raised two daughters.
And it has been interesting
to raise children in a culture
other than the one
in which you grew up,
which is a challenge
all to itself.
I was wondering because the
times have changed so much
since you were 12, how were
you able to inhabit the mind
of a 12-year-old who was--
let's say is on Snapchat or--
but was this--
I haven't read the book.
I read many, many reviews of it.
I'm interested to read
it and your other books.
But I was wondering
how you did that.
Because for me, one of the
difficult aspects of parenting
has been to penetrate into
the mind of someone who
is culturally different, or
grew up with different things
that they saw or experienced.
I just was wondering
if some of it
was based on your experience,
or if it was just--
Well, I think there are
various things I'd say.
One is that it's set in
a very particular moment.
And so it's largely
pre Snapchat.
But this became a thing
because it corresponded--
I think the girls are a
year older than my daughter.
But it corresponded to--
I've driven the car for
a lot of teenage kids
for a bunch of time.
And so certain cultural
references and so on, I--
but it was also the
moment of the iPod Touch.
The moment when they're in
sort of sixth and seventh grade
is the moment of
the iPod Touch--
which I don't know if
you remember that device.
But it played music, and it
would text if you had Wi-Fi.
But it didn't have
anything beyond that.
And it didn't take pictures.
And it didn't-- so
their evolution--
by the time they're in
ninth grade, those things--
ninth grade corresponds to the
beginning of Instagram and I
think Snapchat in their world.
But that's very much
towards the end of the book.
So there is the
strangeness right now
that even from one
year to another,
teenagers' experiences change.
So my daughter, for example,
has explained to me,
we don't do Facebook.
Those kids are two
years older than me.
We Instagram and Snapchat.
And there were Vines, but Vine
has gone the way of all things.
But it's a very specific--
and that's very different
because there was a whole
generation of people for whom
Facebook was the--
has been and still continues
to be the sort of focus
of a great deal of life.
But in her generation,
no, literally by a year.
I also think one of
the things about--
and I know-- so my parents,
my mother's Canadian,
and my father's French.
I was raised around and about,
but ultimately in the end here.
And I'm realizing that
your upbringing is weird.
I realized at some point
that my upbringing was,
compared to other
people's, pretty weird.
And I realized in
the editing process
that my kids' upbringings
have been weird.
There were-- I had references--
I think I was allowed to keep
one, but-- to Marilyn Monroe.
And I was told, nope, no.
Young people don't know
who Marilyn Monroe is.
And I said, well, at
my house, the kids
know who Marilyn Monroe is.
I mean there were just
all of these things
that I realized that we
clearly have imparted.
So the oddity of our household
has imparted stuff to the--
I mean Marilyn
Monroe is hardly odd.
But we could find other things.
But anyway, the point being
that the question in my mind
becomes not is this a
representative adolescent?,
but do I believe this
adolescent could exist
in this country in this time?
And I feel pretty certain
that I do believe that.
And indeed, my poor daughter,
I made her read the manuscript
and make--
which I had never done before
and hope never to do again.
It's not-- she has
to live with me.
But she said, this, no.
This, no.
Change this.
Thank you to you both.
I was very interested,
Homi, in what
you were saying
about the narrator
not being a fixed, static one.
And I was thinking about
Judith Butler's Giving
an Account of Oneself
and how narration
can change when we
narrate ourselves
in the face of another.
And there's even sort of
a vulnerability to that.
And I'm wondering if that
played into your mind
at all in terms of what made the
voice of the narration change
vis-a-vis her
relationships in the text.
Are you asking Homi that?
Well, let me tell
you what struck
me was the inadequacy
both of what
Claire called the taxonomy,
the kind of binary taxonomy,
while reading this
book, but also
about the kind of
moral and critical ways
in which we talk
about the consistency
or authenticity of--
first person narrative
is what I'm talking about.
Now the issue about
first person narrative
is that it's somewhat
different, I think,
than the idea of the notion of
performativity in narrative,
where it is assumed that there
is another of a certain kind.
Yeah.
Now the interesting thing
with first person narrative
is that the person who narrates
is constructing the narrative
on the basis of a projected,
or cited, otherness.
Do you see what I'm saying?
So there is-- so in
creating the dialogue,
you are creating at the same
time your own authority,
your own authority.
Now what's interesting here
is that the mise-en-scene,
the continual-- as I found
it, the shift in location--
not just the shift in relational
persons, but the shift in
locations elicited a different
kind of narrative persona,
and a narrative place,
and a narrative position.
And in technical
terms, I would say this
is less about Judy Butler--
and not only, but of course
through that whole tradition
of the performance--
and more about the
notion of enunciation.
That in any particular
moment institutionally,
structurally, spatially,
and temporally, you
are continually using a kind
of GPS, whatever it's called,
global positioning system.
And that keeps changing.
So to demand-- at
the end of the day,
is this reliable or unreliable?
Is this authentic
or unauthentic?
It doesn't really give you
the measure of transition
as you're getting it, as
I see it in this book.
Because the transitional
doesn't move in that way.
It has a-- you see
what I'm saying.
It has a particular location,
and that location can change.
So it's as much about place
as it is about the continuity
or discontinuity of person.
It's that more
phenomenological relationship
that I thought that
this book played out--
where in the early chapters,
going to the asylum
was both a place of refuge,
but also a large metaphor
of paranoia, of hiding.
In fact, there's a line here.
I couldn't find it when I tried
to, when I needed it again.
But there was a--
she always felt
that in her anxiety,
she was tinged with
a certain paranoia.
There's a-- I don't know if
that's the word, but some--
or fear or--
so that's what interested me,
the way in which a location can
create an affect for
a particular voice
or a particular relationship
to a place, to a time.
And that's very different
from this endlessly iterative
performativity circus--
in my view, with respect.
No offense.
No offense meant.
Maybe?
Maybe that's--
OK.
Well, thank you so much.
Thank you, all.
Thank you, Homi.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]